I got the real clown here the queen
clown hi everyone I'm Bella Dylan and I
am a professional makeup artist what
made me create the clown contouring was
a collaboration that I did with another
makeup artist basically came out with
the idea to respond to however they hate
that we were getting on social media
I personally was called the clown all
the time I said well i'ma show you what
a real clown looks like I'm able to
express myself through makeup today I'm
gonna be showing you the clown
contouring on someone else and I'm also
going to be doing highlighting contour
on different skin tools and we're gonna
have fun with it
my relationship with makeup does not
exist makeup terrifies me I love makeup
I just suck at it so bad I've walked
into a couple of makeup stores I
remember in high school and that just
scared me I have a vision when I put on
makeup and I want that vision to
actually be realized and actually look
like how I see it in my head I think I'm
excited to do something totally
different than I usually do this will be
the first time that anyone will see me
with makeup on turn me into Kim
Kardashian
I'm feeling a little Ruby Bros vibe so
we're gonna go ahead and and do that I'm
glad I can't see the process just
because like when you watch like YouTube
videos or whatever they look crazy
the BuzzFeed clown contour face forward
put eyes up yeah face forward yeah see
how it's light medium and then dark so
when you blend that it's actually gonna
be much easier the reason why we put all
these different colors on her face some
are gonna act as blush so I'm just gonna
act like a color corrector some
obviously is gonna highlight and contour
the face so I'm putting a lightweight
foundation what I'm doing is I'm just
color matching you and then I'll go in
there with a little bit of highlight and
then I'll go in with a little bit of
contour as well
I can't wait to blend everything
together
I have no idea what I look like my face
actually feels less oily I'm really
excited to look oh my god I look really
badass oh my god
I'm like afraid to look again damn guy
would never know that I look like a
clown before this I feel like I'm a
painting my best Ruby let Rose look oh I
can give you like a little eyebrow thing
I like that it's made makeup not as
intimidating it kind of has to happen in
steps even if like I love the way I look
without makeup by putting on certain
types of makeup or certain colors like
it enhances my personality that I want
to show through I probably won't do this
on my own
it was just nice to learn a little bit
about like even basic makeup this is art
though I appreciate those